four members of the Senate introduced
legislation on Wednesday that would ban
minor minors under the age of 13.
from using social media and mandate
parental consent for those younger than
18.
the bill called the protecting kids on
social media act would also prohibit the
use of algorithmic content
recommendations for all minors in order
to reduce the addictive elements of
social media
the bill is sponsored by looks like two
Democrats and two Republicans so it's a
bipartisan bill
one of the Democrats Brian Schatz his
actual last name says the growing
evidence is clear social media is making
kids more depressed and wreaking havoc
on their mental health while kids are
suffering social media companies are
profiting this needs to stop our bill
will help us stop the growing social
media Health crisis
um among kids by setting a minimum age
and preventing companies from using
algorithms to automatically feed them
addictive content based on their
personal information
uh
now I'd have to I'd have to re I haven't
read the actual bill I have to read more
into it but just on surface level based
on the uh quick description of it I'm in
favor of it
I think it's a very good idea but
there's also as I said an interesting
contrast here because you have at least
some Democrats who are willing to say
that you know kids under shouldn't a
certain age shouldn't be exposed to this
at all like kids under 13 shouldn't be
on social media at all should be banned
from being honored is what the bill says
I agree
there's there's no good reason for
an 11 year old child to be on social
media no good can come from it it cannot
help them it's like there's zero chance
of it helping them in any way
and there's a great chance that it hurts
them so when you're putting a child on
social media giving a child access to
social media you are doing something
that for that child it's all downside
and there is zero upside
uh the only upside
really this is why parents do it is that
it gets them out of your hair and it
occupies them so that you don't have to
deal with them but that's not really
upside
that's not upside for them right that's
an upside for you in your laziness but
it's not an upside for them it's not
going to benefit them
so I totally agree no no kid under 13
should be on social media I don't think
any kids should be on social media
period at any age
because the same rule applies 16 year
olds how do they benefit from being on
social media I know why they want to be
on it
understand that
but do they benefit does it make them a
better person well make them healthier
happier we'll do any of that is there
any chance
okay is there any chance that uh your
kid will uh you know make it into
adulthood and then and then look back on
their childhood without social media and
lament and say I wish I was using social
media all that time
you think you're ever gonna find it be
at a point as a parent
years down the line when you say to
yourself I wish my kid had spent more
time on social media if only now that
would never happen
if you don't know uh where your meat
comes from then you should change the
way you buy me today and uh the way to
do that is by using our friends good
ranchers because they take this
incredibly seriously you deserve me that
you can confidently serve to your family
without fear of what's in it you also
deserve delicious meat with unmatched
quality you deserve all of that I
personally subscribe to good ranchers
not only is their meat fantastic but
they're also giving you free bacon for a
year a 240 value that's a pound and a
half of bacon in every box in fact just
two days ago I got my most recent good
ranchers uh delivery and we're uh we
have it on the we get it every six weeks
uh we have it coming in so we should be
good for the next six weeks good
ranchers offers a price lock guarantee
just another great way to beat inflation
their products are unlike any other I
can tell you from experience they're all
natural Burgers USDA prime steaks and
better than organic chicken have changed
my standard for grape meat and will
change yours too you can use my code
Walsh for an extra 20 off your order how
can American meat get any better well
good ranchers has already done it over 1
million meals to local food banks and
they're just getting started support
American Farms and Ranchers with good
ranchers today head to goodranchors.com
use my code Walsh for 20 off your box
free bacon great meat secure price a
bonus 20 off today you can't lose it's a
win-win situation that's promo code
Walsh at goodranchors.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
your online data includes personal
information such as your name address
phone number email address financial
information and login credentials
hackers want to steal this information
and sell it on the dark web for uh where
they can use it for various criminal
activities such as fishing ransomware
and identity theft needless to say it's
incredibly important that you use a VPN
to prevent that from happening but
choosing a VPN you trust is equally as
important that's why we recommend using
expressvpn every time you go online
expressvpn makes you anonymous online by
camouflaging your IP address and
replacing with a different secure IP of
your choice expressvpn also encrypts all
of your data so that it's protected from
hackers and anyone else that's trying to
spy on you I love expressvpn because it
doesn't log your activity lots of cheap
or free vpns make money by selling your
data to advertisers but expressvpn
doesn't do that they've even developed a
technology that makes their VPN servers
incapable of storing any data at all
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up the app click one button
and that's it plus it works on all of my
devices my phone my laptop
even my Wi-Fi router so if you're like
me and you believe that your internet
data belongs to you then expressvpn is
the answer of visit
expressvpn.comwall should get three
months free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh to
learn more
but there are going to be a lot of kids
as they get older
who deeply mental event how much time
they spent on it and many parents who
regret allowing it
agree with all that but obviously the
hypocrisy here is that at least you have
some Democrats who can see that kids
under certain age shouldn't be on social
media and yet
um
it seems almost certain that those same
Democrats and I don't know I could look
it up these particular Democrats what's
their position on this
but almost every Democrat is fully on
board with kids taking gender transition
drugs puberty blockers chemical
castration
as if a bill like this passes we're
going to be in a situation where you
know on the federal level Nationwide we
we have declared that 12 year old
children are not old enough to use
Twitter they are not old enough to use
tick tock
um but they are old enough
to take castration drugs they are old
enough for for hormone therapy it
sterilizes them
that doesn't make any sense
that doesn't make any sense but
considering this bill on its own you
know in a vacuum uh it does make sense
to me and look I I understand
the argument and I've heard this even
from plenty of people on the right that
this is this is a parental rights thing
and parents should be able to make the
decision
um
I I don't
I don't see it as parental rights
anymore than you know setting an age
limit for alcohol setting an age limit
for tobacco setting an age limit even
for R-rated movies
uh I
I don't see it as a parental rights
issue any more than those things are
and and most people now if you take a
really purest libertarian stance on this
if you're an absolutist libertarian type
then you probably say well yeah there
shouldn't be any age limit for those
things either right blood parents make
up their own mind
but most people aren't really troubled
by the fact that there's a drinking age
and we could argue about how effective
the drinking age is and all the rest of
it but most people there's not a real I
there's there's not much of a movement
to lower the drinking age to 16 or 14 or
to get rid of it entirely most people
are okay with that
because they understand that it's just
it yeah even if you set it set an age
for it that's not actually gonna
stop
right if a kid really wants to drink
they're still going to be able to do it
but we're still at a minimum like at a
minimum we're at least making a
statement as a society that this is not
something that kids should be doing
and there's no benefit to to throwing
open the doors of the liquor store and
say yeah 13 year olds come on in
and so that's why the laws are in place
the way they are and I think it's the
same thing with social media
in fact I think you could make a very
good argument that kids uh uh you know
that that
um open kind of unfettered access and
exposure to social media is even more
damaging for kids
than alcohol
um I think you could make that argument
because it damages them at a at an even
deeper level like it's affecting the
kind of person that you you are and that
you'll become it's affecting your your
mind of course alcohol does that too
obviously but uh I think even in an even
deeper level
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to members block you can
become a member today by using Code wall
should check out for two months free on
all annual plans
um
see over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign